لذلك أمضى مكتب سي إن إن في بكين
أسبوعًا في كتابة التقارير في
مقاطعة شينجيانغ الغربية الصينية ، وهو ليس
مكانًا سهلاً لممارسة الصحافة ، لذلك أردنا
أن نعرض لكم القليل مما مررنا به ،
لكنني أعتقد أن الأهم من ذلك أن
أخبركم عن سبب أهمية ذلك  شين جانغ
هي المقاطعة التي تقول الولايات المتحدة إن الصين
احتجزت فيها ما يصل إلى مليوني شخص تقريبًا
جميع المسلمين في المعسكرات على مدار السنوات القليلة
الماضية.
في الداخل أثناء
خضوعها للتلقين السياسي ،
تنفي الصين ذلك وتقول إن هذه المعسكرات
ليست سجونًا ولكنها
مراكز تدريب مهني تطوعية تُستخدم
ليس للقضاء على الإسلام فقط
التطرف الإسلامي الآن تقول الحكومة الصينية
إن شين جانغ مفتوحة على مصراعيها لنا
للإبلاغ بحرية عن احتمال وجودها.  من الناحية النظرية ولكن
هذا ليس صحيحًا في الواقع ،
على سبيل المثال عند الهبوط هناك
كانت هديتنا الترحيبية قصة حكومية
كنا نتبعها بالفعل  قام ثلاثة أو أربعة
رجال ، بما في ذلك أحدهم الذين رأوا
يتابعنا من الثانية التي خرجنا منها من
منطقة الأمتعة التي سيكون هذا الرجل
هو وعشرات آخرين على الأقل
تابعونا كل ساعة من رحلتنا التي تستغرق ستة أيام
على بعد أكثر من 20 قدمًا في السيارة
في محطة القطار بالفندق في
الغرفة المجاورة لغرفتي ، لذا كان
شعورًا غريبًا على الأقل بالنسبة للرجال
الذين كانوا يتابعوننا
خلال الأيام القليلة الماضية ، فقد شعرت وكأنها
تكتيكات تخويف  لقد أرادوا منا أن
نعرف أنه تمت ملاحقتنا ومن
ثم بالطبع كان هناك رجال شرطة يرتدون الزي الرسمي
ظهروا في ساعات غريبة
تقريبًا نعم أعرف ولكني كنت
نائمًا
، يبدو الأمر غير ضروري ،
آسف حسنًا ، هذا ما يحدث
عندما تمارس الصحافة  وظيفة آلة عشت
هنا منذ ما يقرب من أربع سنوات ،
وشاهدت أن الأمور أصبحت أكثر صرامة
وأكثر صرامة بالنسبة للصحفيين الأجانب في
جميع أنواع القصص المختلفة ،
ربما يكون شين جون مجرد المثال الأكثر تطرفًا
ولكن أبعد من مجرد
كانت هناك محاولات أكثر وضوحًا
لمحاولة التأكد من أننا لم نر شيئًا
لم يرغبوا في أن نقوم به ، على سبيل المثال ، كان
الطريق السريع الذي كنا فيه مغلقًا لساعات
بسبب وقوع حادث في أي مكان لا يمكن رؤيته
ناهيك عن حواجز الطرق العفوية
التي  استهداف الأجانب
والأقليات العرقية ، تم فحص بطاقات الهوية الخاصة بنا
ما يقرب من 50 مرة في 6 أيام ، وفي المرة الثانية
التي حجزت فيها رحلة طيران أو قطار
تعرف الحكومة به ، ويمكنك
معرفة ذلك نظرًا لأن
المسؤولين الحكوميين في انتظارك جيدًا عند
وصولهم ، فقد علموا بوضوح أننا كنا
عند وصولهم إلى المطار ، قاموا
بفحص تأشيراتنا ، وأخبرونا
أنهم يريدون مرافقتنا من أجل سلامتنا الخاصة ،
لكن هذا في الحقيقة مجرد
تكتيكات للمماطلة يعرفون أنها نعرفها ومع
ذلك فهذه هي اللعبة التي يجب أن نلعبها
صرحت وزارة الخارجية الصينية أنها
لا تعرف شيئًا عن المضايقات التي
واجهناها ، لكنها قالت إن شين جيانج
منفتحة ومضياف ، وأن
ذيول المضايقات المستمرة
والتأخيرات المستمرة  إنها أكثر من مجرد
إزعاج ، فهي تكتيكات محددة
استخدمتها حكومة الصين لفترة
طويلة لمنع الصحفيين من
أداء وظائفهم ، لكن في السنوات القليلة
الماضية ، كان هناك اتفاق واسع في
مجتمع الصحافة الأجنبية هنا على أن الوضع
أصبح أسوأ في أي مكان أكثر من
شين تشاو النتيجة النهائية هي أنه
يكاد يكون من المستحيل الإبلاغ بحرية
عن مئات الآلاف من الأشخاص الذين
يُحتمل أنهم يقبعون في المعسكرات في الوقت
الحالي وهذا يعني أن بقية
العالم لا يستطيع حقًا رؤية ما يحدث
هناك ، هذا واحد من  أكبر
قصص حقوق الإنسان على وجه الأرض وكما رأينا
مباشرة ، تحاول الصين
التستر عليها